bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
hoy nos acompaña josep borrell alto
representante de la unión europea para
asuntos exteriores él se encuentra en
madrid españa que es además su país de
nacimiento señor borrero buenos días y
gracias por estar con nosotros
hola buenos días bueno la guerra en
ucrania ya va a cumplir dos meses usted
junto con la presidenta de la comisión
europea ursula von der leyen estuvo en
ayer hablando con el presidente s lens
que estuvo en abuya donde se cometieron
como usted mismo ha declarado crímenes
de guerra en este momento que tan viable
ve usted la posibilidad de sentarse a
negociar un alto al fuego con la rusia
no parece que rusia tenga ningunas ganas
de hacerlo
el canciller de austria viajó a moscú
hace unos días para pedirle al
presidente putin que parara la guerra y
que negociará la paz pero la respuesta
fuera negativa a la guerra va a
continuar según putin ha dicho no quiere
pararla está concentrando más y más
tropas en la región del donbass hoy ha
empezado una nueva ofensiva el
bombardeos masivos del ejército ruso
contra varias ciudades
ojalá fuera posible un alto fuego y una
negociación nosotros estamos trabajando
para eso pero la postura de rusia es
clara la guerra va a continuar y ucrania
tiene que defenderse
claramente usted decía que han ahora han
comenzado pues los ataques de manera
mucho más fuerte en el donbass y
justamente el 9 de mayo rusia celebra
esa gran fiesta de la victoria la
victoria en la segunda guerra mundial se
cree que vladimir putin quisiera
declarar victoria también sobre ucrania
en esa fecha de aquí allá hay que
esperar entonces a que se presenten aún
más muertes de civiles a que haya
también pues una oleada de ataques son
más agresivos
desgraciadamente eso parece sí
exactamente es así
ahora hablemos de las sanciones en la
unión europea ya va por ese quinto
paquete de sanciones contra moscú se
acordó ya el embargo a la carbón que
entrará en vigor a partir del próximo
mes de agosto pero por ahora no hay
decisiones concretas sobre el embargo
sobre los hidrocarburos en el petróleo y
sobre todo el gas rusos desde el
comienzo a esta guerra además la unión
europea pues ha pagado más de 35 mil
millones de euros en hidrocarburos anh a
rusia
en que van estas negociaciones entre los
27 para poner fin a esta dependencia
energética que finalmente es también un
arma en manos de moscú
bueno todo el mundo sin necesidad de que
haya un acuerdo está haciendo lo que
puede para reducir esta dependencia a
todo el mundo está reconociendo de
manera voluntaria y todo lo que puede
las importaciones de gas y el petróleo
una acción conjunta que el pase por una
prohibición es algo que todavía no se ha
conseguido
pero en lo que se refiere el petróleo
estoy seguro de que llegará llegará
pronto porque el caso del petróleo es
más fácil de sustituir que en el caso de
gas ahí no hay un acuerdo todavía para
hacerlo pero ya le digo de una forma
individual y voluntaria todo el mundo
está reduciendo y llegará un momento en
que se va para una prohibición expresa
pero claro hay que buscar alternativas
de la noche a la mañana cuando se
consume un 40% de gas por ejemplo de una
fuente determinada es difícil cerrarla
si no se encuentra una alternativa que
la sustituya
y en eso está en los países de una
manera quizá demasiado cada uno por su
lado estamos intentando coordinar lo
desde bruselas pero desde el oriente
medio desde el golfo desde argelia de
eeuu desde noruega desde el reino unido
se está buscando nuevas fuentes de
aprovisionamiento para acabar cuanto
antes
con esta dependencia
justamente usted hablaba del oriente
medio' hablaba de estos otros países con
los que se podría entrar a negociar para
abastecerse especialmente en gas
justamente hubo ese foro también en en
doha en qatar pero los qataríes dijeron
que no le van a dar una prioridad de la
unión europea para abastecerlo en gas
sobre los contratos que ya tienen
firmados con países asiáticos
naturalmente los contratos se cumplen
contratos que el qatar tiene firmados
nos va a cumplir faltaría más no le
pedimos que incumpla contratos para
beneficiarnos a nosotros lo que pedimos
es que los contratos spot aquellos que
se hacen al día a día los haga con
nosotros y también que aumente sus
capacidades de producción y qatar lo va
a hacer
qatar va a aumentar sus capacidades de
producción pero como le decía antes de
esta clase del problema no tienen
soluciones milagrosas ni instantáneas la
producción se va a aumentar pero va a
llevar un tiempo y naturalmente no le
pedimos a qatar que cumpla los contratos
que tiene con terceros muy bien
justamente también hablando de toda esta
dependencia energética de rusia por
ahora lo cierto es que esta guerra
también ha mostrado que ha sido una
prueba de fuego para la unidad de los 27
por ahora se ha mostrado sólida pero en
vista de que no hay un consenso en
cuanto a las sanciones sobre el petróleo
en especial el gas rusos hay países
reticentes como alemania austria pero
también hungría cuyo presidente de hecho
hace poco dijo que no iba a dejar de
pagar hidrocarburos a rusia para no
desestabilizar su economía será que ese
tema va a ser el talón de aquiles de esa
unidad
como les digo en ese caso concreto no
hay un acuerdo si tuviera ya lo
habríamos aplicado pero en el caso de
ucrania la unión europea ha demostrado
una unión mucho más fuerte y mucho más
rápida que ninguna otra crisis en todos
los aspectos en todos en sanciones
económicas financieras sectoriales
bancarias
exportaciones e importaciones han tomado
de decisiones más de 1000 personas
sancionadas
cuyos activos han sido congelados y que
están prohibidos a su acceso a europa
nunca habíamos hecho tanto en tan poco
tiempo la entrega de armas financiadas
con el presupuesto europeo
si nos falta todavía el petróleo y el
gas porque son aspectos en los que no
tendría sentido hacernos más daño a
nosotros del que le causamos al otro una
sanción se supone que causa más daño al
sancionado que el sancionador y si no es
así más vale no tomarla pero también en
ese terreno habrá avance estamos
empujando por ello estoy convencido de
que la limitación o la prohibición
aplicar impuestos a las importaciones
sobre petróleo en particular van a
llegar pronto y mientras tanto se hace
lo que sea puede a nivel de cada país
hungría no lo querrá hacer muy bien pero
siente cuentas hungría es un pequeño
país que pesa poco la balanza energética
europea lo importante es lo que hagan
los grandes países y todo que yo están
convencidos de la necesidad de reducir
la dependencia de rusia muy bien yo sé
ocurre usted va a viajar pronto a
américa latina podría decirnos a qué
países
va a viajar y también pensé cuál es el
objetivo de este viaje
y esperamos poder viajar mucho más de lo
que lo hemos hecho por culpa de ala
cohete para reforzar nuestros lazos y
defender la posición de europa en esta
guerra frente al resto del mundo la
comunidad internacional en particular
aquella que no se es próxima y afín como
esa américa latina y que ha estado en
las naciones unidas- del lado del
derecho internacional no del lado de
europa del lado del derecho
internacional tiene que saber que nos
preocupamos por estrechar los lazos con
ellos están en chile y luego asisten a
la reunión de ministros de asuntos
exteriores de américa central en panamá
pero todos los responsables europeos
tenemos que viajar más tenemos que estar
más cerca de los países que no son
cercanos próximos amigos y también de
aquellos que no lo son tanto porque va a
haber una batalla de ideas va a haber
una batalla de narrativas donde rusia
intentará hacer creer al mundo que la
penuria la crisis energética la crisis
alimentaria es consecuencia de las
sanciones que le hemos impuesto cuando
entré
son consecuencia de la guerra que ya ha
empezado
si no hay trigo es porque el ucraniano
puede exportar y si no puede exportar es
porque la flota rusa bloquea las
exportaciones y sus aviones destruyen
los stocks de trigo si va a haber un
problema alimentario en el mundo y hay
que explicar por qué hay que buscar las
soluciones como el gas si usted deja de
producir consumir ricard ruso tiene que
buscar otra fuente de gas si no hay gas
porque rusia impide que lo haya si no
hay trigo porque rusia impide que lo
haya habrá que buscar otra fuente
alternativa otros tendrán que producir
más para compensar la menor
disponibilidad de que de trigo ucraniano
y ruso de lo contrario tendremos
problemas de inventarios algunos países
que pueden producir graves alteraciones
sociales graves problemas en el mundo de
hambre los ingresos la comunidad
internacional lo tiene que combatir de
una forma coordinada
precisamente usted en enero de este año
había dicho que había que ir más a
américa latina como incluso acaba de
decirlo la idea su viaje es poder
contrarrestar la influencia rusa y china
en esa región no tanto en países como
venezuela o como cuba sino también en
países como argentina brasil el salvador
y de alguna forma evitar que se vuelva a
presentar esa digamos esa dicotomía
geopolítica de la guerra fría
bueno no exageremos la influencia de
china en rusia en américa latina no está
al nivel de una guerra fría pero si es
rusia y china les particular china china
está muy presente de todas partes del
mundo y también en américa latina con
sus inversiones con la compra masiva de
materias primas que desea soja argentina
o que sea cobre chileno chinas o un gran
cliente un agente
importantísimo en el mundo y es natural
que esté allí no nos preocupa que se
extienda a sus actividades como nosotros
también lo hacemos pero si nos preocupa
la influencia política que puede
derivarse de ello a fin de cuentas de
américa latina es la parte del mundo más
europea la que más parecida es a europa
en sus su fisionomía urbana buenos aires
podría ser perfectamente una ciudad
europea
la tradición la historia la cultura la
lengua la religión
todo eso nos une estructuras políticas
muy parecidas a las nuestras porque
también fueron creadas en el mismo
tiempo que nosotros en el siglo 19 por
lo tanto en esta cercanía américa latina
no es solamente por españa es por las
estructuras políticas que tenemos tal
vez en próximas unas a otras es muy
importante hay que cultivarla hay que
cultivarla porque a veces como sabes que
tu primo te quiere no 39 nos toma la
molestia de decirse luego de visitarle
hemos de poner américa latina más alta
en la agenda europea e invertimos
muchísimo en américa latina en términos
financieros y quizá no tanto en términos
políticos hay que corregir eso muy bien
pues espero esperaremos a ver esa
corrección y que américa latina tome un
poco más de importancia en la agenda
europeas josep borràs gracias por
habernos acompañado
gracias a ustedes hasta aquí esta
entrevista de france 24 por favor
continúen con nuestra programación
[Música]